brand new YouTube channel in 2023 how
can you utilize this first step to set
yourself up ultimately to know that you
can succeed in the end yeah so reverse
engineer is all about starting with the
end in mind and it's about answering the
questions of who is your channel for
what problem does your channel solve
it's also about getting Clarity of what
is the business plan for your channel if
you're trying to reach everybody you'll
end up reaching nobody if you're trying
to monetize in every possible Creator
Economy Way your focus is too divided
there's better monetization options for
entertainment and there's different ones
for Education it's it's getting clear on
those types of things it's getting clear
on who is your target audience and the
cool thing about the 7R framework is you
can apply it first to your channel so
we're talking about reverse engineer
what's your Channel about what's the
focus of the channel what's The Branding
of the channel but you also then apply
it to individual videos
so you're maybe posting a video and
saying what's the purpose of this video
is it more of a broad appeal bring in
more subscribers is it more of a it
could be something as like a channel
update you don't think it's going to
perform well but you are wanting to talk
to a small number of people that are
actually see it that's fine You just
defined ahead of time what the purpose
is what I found is I was really inspired
by a 2 000 year old quote from a
military General named Sun Tzu the book
is very famous it's called The Art of
War and he said that every battle is won
before it's even fought so could it be
that your success on YouTube getting a
thousand subscribers a hundred thousand
subscribers that actually you're gonna
win that battle before you even post a
video and we say punch fear in the face
start before you're ready there's
something about like you should be doing
that anyways like just learning
practicing but when it really comes down
to winning on YouTube and building
something significant you want to have a
cohesive strategy and that definitely
starts with defining your end targets
and getting really clear on some of
those questions I just put out there